[Music]
so uh i was wondering how to uh
introduce this talk and um
i have a friend who uh was on the zoom
meeting we have lots of headless way
zoom meetings
throughout the week free anyone's
welcome to drop in if you're interested
and um
this friend american was saying that
he was driving to the market with his
dad
and he said well i've got to be back at
12 for the zoom meeting the headless way
zoom meeting
and his dad said oh what's that then
and rick said uh well just notice you're
driving you can see the wheel
you can see your arms reaching out
and
but you can't see your head
you can't see your head
and
his dad said yeah i get that you see
it was a pause and he went
but what the hell does that mean
and i was talking to ricky and he said
well it's very easy in a way to notice
you can't see your head
but how what does it mean
so
i don't have long but i'm going to share
with you
the experience and the meaning
the experience is incredibly simple
but i'm just it's about your identity
it's about what you are here and now in
your own experience
and it's something that strictly
speaking no one can tell you
about
because only you are you
only you are right where you are only
you are looking out
right now the place you're looking out
of only you can feel your breathing
and what i'm going to do is share a few
awareness exercises
that
i think direct our attention
to this place that is nearer to you than
your breathing
now
uh you've probably come across spiritual
ideas that say your true nature
is boundless still
open timeless
and this is a great treasure to become
aware of what you really are
and that's what i am here to share with
you
and it's not a wow it's not a high
it's something incredibly simple
but it is uh i've been uh
exploring this for more than 50 years
i think in the description of this
talk mentioned the guy called douglas
harding so i met him more than 50 years
ago
and i'm just going to show you
a map
of you
can you see that
so it's like a mandala
and this is based on the the observation
that what you are
changes with the range of the observer
so i'm not going to go on
about this for a long time i'm going to
get to the experience
but you can see me
and what i look like
depends on how far away you are if
you're in the front row i look different
from what i look like in the background
and if you could come up to me that
you'd lose all of richard and just get
my face
and if you could come closer
it's in principle verifiable you get
patch your skin and then you'll get
cells and then you get molecules
and then you'd get atoms
and if you the nearer you get to me here
the less there is
until you on contact there's practically
nothing
and if you went away then you would find
eventually richard and then the the
festival and then england and the planet
and the star and the galaxy
these are all layers of your body
there's a new way of thinking about
yourself and you identify with these
letters i identify with richard i'll
identify in my family i identify with my
nation i hope i identify with my planet
identify with the ancient shoulder
so uh
identity is
elastic now the question is what are you
at the center of all those layers
clearly no one can tell you because only
you are there
so i'm going to ask you to look
it's incredibly simple
to look at what it's like at zero
and
this is scientific in a way it's not
asking you to believe anything it's
asking you to pay attention
so the heart of what i'm asking you to
do is meditation it's attention
and it is first attention to what you're
looking out at and then attention to the
place you're looking from
so i'm going to ask you to do something
very simple and childlike
and a bit embarrassing in public
but i'll do it and
we won't tell anybody
and it's about directing your attention
attention
so what i want you to do is to point
at
something in front of you and look along
your finger or what you're pointing at
so i know this is the embarrassing bit
so please if you'd like and that what
this does there you go you're directing
your attention
and it's much better if you do it so
look along your finger and you see a
thing i'm pointing at a pole it's got
shape and a color this is as simple as
that now point down at the floor you see
you're directing your attention
attention
and you might like the floor you might
not like the floor you might understand
how it was made or you might not it
doesn't matter you can see it
point at your foot
another thing you can
even move it
come up your body point at your knee you
see you're looking you're directing your
attention with your finger
point at your chest
again you can see something there
now here's the important point point
back at the place other people are
looking at so you can turn your finger
around like i'm doing
now the place you're pointing at now is
zero only you are there do you see your
face i don't
do you see your head there i don't
i if i was to put into words i say no
face no head open space full of the
finger and the whole festival
and all you've done there is direct your
attention first out and then come closer
and closer like in the map towards the
center
until you come right to the place that
no one else can see
everyone else is going to tell you i can
see your head there richard i say yeah
but you're over there
i'm here
my body is headless you see for me for
years i know i've got a body with a head
and this is the difference between the
third person and the first person the
view from outside at a certain range in
the view from inside
so here's another map
this is a first person view is the view
out a headless body there
now if you open your arms a bit you'll
see that your arms embrace the whole
room if you just do that like that map
you see my arms only embrace a little
bit of the stage but i've left
the first person embraces the world
and you look out into your
world
now this emptiness this void
you see
if you hold your hand out like this this
way you've got to do something to
to really benefit from it just hold your
hand out and what i'm going to ask you
to do is bring it back past your head
you see
now do that again and everyone else sees
your hand going past your head third
person outside view first person is my
hand gets bigger and then disappears
into the great void
and then comes out of nothing
this is so freeing you see
so freeing
i am spaced for you i am you
from the outside is it here someone
might say well so what
ears are so big so what
in terms of relationships
from the outside we are head to head if
you look at me and someone else with
face to face we're separate okay i get
that
now pay attention to my own point of
view and be in my own authority and what
it's like to be me and i look at you and
it's face to nerve face
face to no face face to nerve i have
your face i trade faces you've got my
face there
and you can tell me about it i've got
your face here i am you this is
absolutely a game changer
i have now 100 faces
hydra
yes
we've been known about this for
thousands of years
this is a modern way of directing your
attention to your true nature we call
this a single eye
now
you can see i've got two eyes little
holes in the head here this is
incredibly simple isn't it
but i tell you i'm not looking out of
two little holes in the meatball here
i'm looking at one vast single opening
cyclops
now take your hand you see and see it
disappears
into the top of your single eye you see
or the side
it's vast how wide is that single eye
it's wider than the tent
you are big
from the outside you're small i from the
outside i'm small
now this makes sense in terms of
personal development there are four main
stages the baby the child the adult and
the seer the baby's headless pre-verbal
you're open we love babies because they
give us but made permission to be
headless
you see how i'm putting it in my terms
but a baby's just open pre-verbal lovely
now as you're growing up through
language you learn to see yourself as
others see you in imagination you go out
and see yourself as others see you
that is becoming aware of who you are as
an individual
as learning your name your nationality
your gender and all of that
you see and you have to learn that in
order to understand i have to understand
i'm richard on the stage i didn't know
that as a baby if i was a baby i'd be
going
no i you see no idea of being a baby we
were all in that blessed condition you
see to begin with
but then as we grow up through language
people feedback what you are and you
look in the mirror now if you look in
the mirror innocently where is your face
it's there it's not here
but what you learn to do is to take that
face and turn it around and put it on
and wear it we call it the face game
and you become aware of your appearance
you can't see it but you become aware of
it self-consciousness
or your whole body
you see and that's what everyone else is
seeing so as a child you are in two
worlds you're headless and you're
getting your head on you're nobody and
free and carefree and
just seeing what happens and you're
learning to be a person responsible for
what you say and do
and both go together in the when we're
five six seven it's a beautiful age
because we're not yet in the box of our
appearance we're living from our
openness our source
but we've got some idea of how we're
going down and who we are wonderful
but then what happens is the feedback 24
7 is you're a person
you're not space for the world you're a
person you're not the source of the
world you're a product of the world you
see
and so there's
who could resist that so by the time
we're adults
i say i am what i look like i have no
doubt about it look in the mirror that's
me
you see and i that i take responsibility
to be a adult is to be aware of who you
are as a person or
as a
family or as a nation
you see it's not not just a person
but we overlook now the first person
what it's like to be yourself which is
being space for the world
you know and sometimes you might have a
drug experience and you get out your box
and then you're back in and how do i how
do i get out again
let's see the the joke is you're never
in
so the adult third stage baby child
adult third stage of the
adult is i'm what i look like i'm face
to face with you i'm separate from you i
was born and i will die
all right
the great advantages of that you know
you couldn't function if you were not
deeply convinced of that but you have
lost something and
perhaps you have a feeling you're
missing something
well you might well be you see
now what i'm suggesting is that there's
a fourth stage here
not just me suggesting the fourth stage
which is real awakening to what it's
like to be you from your point of view
and you've got to be your own authority
because no one else can see it for you
everyone else is saying no no you got a
head you're a person you're a thing you
know you're separate all right got that
but i'm going to pause
on a sunday afternoon in hampstead i'm
just going to pause for a moment and
just be my own authority and look for
myself
you see i'd like your point back again
point back at the place you're looking
out of no one else has the authority to
say what it's like there and i say it's
wide open boundless aware full of the
whole festival
to continue watching this video click
the link in the top left or in the
description below or visit iai.tv for
more debates and talks from the world's
leading thinkers on today's biggest
ideas